hi
how are you doing shelby i'm doing good
steve how are you
i'm fine thanks did you have a good
weekend had a great weekend thank you
and what about you
i had a wonderful weekend we had good
weather for a change
likewise here in portland
yeah okay so what i
thought we would do is talk as before in
sort of more general terms about
language learning and and learning of
french
and maybe compress that a bit and then
we'll also get into your lessons and
we'll do that also a little bit in a
shorter video than before so that we
don't end up with too long a video great
so
uh before we get into the french i just
wanted to share with you some thoughts
that i had about what we're doing so in
a way what we're doing is a form of a
sort of guided instruction you are
exploring
french through the mini stories or
through le pt pass or through songs
you're exploring the language
together we're
finding things in the language
and we talk about them so in a sense uh
we're finding things we're exploring
things you might ask me a question or i
might point something out
to make the language seem less say
intimidating
not with the expectation that you'll
remember those things and i think that's
a very important point in language
learning it's the gradual exposure and
not the attempt to memorize anything and
so and i was thinking you know if we go
for four weeks we'll cover 20 mini
stories
and we're doing a lot of english
speaking
in the next 20 lessons or next four
weeks we'll speak half english half
french as we continue to explore the
language and then the four weeks
following that we will only speak french
barring any but there should be no need
to speak any english
and and what we're doing is we're we're
pointing things out
we're sort of noticing certain things
and as we notice certain things
other things become clearer but always
with the idea that it's that continuing
exposure to the language and you're free
to explore elsewhere you just i want you
to do five many new many stories each
week review the old ones and then you
can go explore songs or lip tips or
whatever else you want okay and so
that's kind of my thought and i was
thinking you know this is something we
can do
for french now with you as sort of a
trial but if
say a person in brazil
wanted to do a guided course in english
where we begin by speaking portuguese
and then slowly portuguese and english
and then only
english
sorry we begin with portuguese
explaining things and then portuguese in
english and then only in english i'd be
quite open to have a having trials of
this kind of a guided course with other
languages if people are interested and i
should say personally
uh you know i've already had exposure
now to arabic persian and turkish but i
intend to go further
east into urdu
and at that point if someone who is an
urdu speaker wants to work with me and
teach me urdu in the same guided course
pattern i think that would be
interesting to explore i think so too i
like the idea well i'm game to do that
for at least for
this french series
all right now i know that
just looking at some of the comments
here
that people often ask the question you
know what do i do when i'm a1 a2 how do
i accumulate words when it's all noise
too
and so part of that is to have this
guided period where we reduce the the
anxiety and and certainly we don't say
here's the structure in this language
you have to memorize that or hear these
words you have to memorize that it's not
about memorization it's about exposing
yourself to the language
and slowly as you notice certain things
and certain things
suddenly start to stick then you start
noticing other things the fog gradually
lifts
so i don't know you've probably had some
of the same questions where people are
so concerned i don't know anything how
can i start i don't you know understand
anything
that's what link is for
exactly
yeah and i think um a big question that
a lot of people have especially when
they're beginners like myself and french
is you know how how do i make that push
from a1 or a2 to the next level to an
intermediate level because even if i
have
some words some phrases some
understanding of the of the grammar um
i'm i'm barely able to put together a
sentence and i don't know how those gaps
are going to get filled in and i don't
feel like i'm
retaining all the vocabulary that i'm
learning so how would you
answer a question like that
well i think that one shouldn't be too
concerned about being able to use the
language like people think if i don't
use it i'll forget it i don't believe
that i think that it takes that that
repeated exposure to the language the
brain starts to get used to the language
at some point you will either either
want to or have an opportunity or a need
to start using it and of course you will
struggle but if you have a solid base in
terms of vocabulary and comprehension
you will develop that ability to use it
so it's it's pointless to to fret
and worry about how you're going to ever
be able to remember those words in order
to be able to use them just continue
enjoying the sort of
you know discovery of the language and
and believe me because i've done it many
times
believe me you will when when the time
comes you'll gradually start to use
more and more of it you don't have to
deliberately memorize you don't have to
study word lists you don't have to do
any of those things you just have to
keep on pushing hopefully in an
enjoyable you know process of discovery
and exploration and the brain will get
used to the language
and i think that we can trust you
because this is the exact same method
that you've used to learn
almost 20 languages right
well that's right and and you know if i
look at your situation learning french
and i don't think i don't notice that
you have a particular level of anxiety
but a lot of people are concerned like
how will i ever learn this language so
someone going from say english to french
has a big advantage it's the same
writing system
it's you know 50
same vocabulary between english and
french and in your case you have spanish
so that's like 85 percent the same
vocabulary but when i started learning
you know greek or persian or arabic
i mean there it's not the same writing
system there's
essentially no common vocabulary so
it was much more difficult was much more
total noise and yet
and i thought i'll never learn this
language i never learned to read to read
it and to understand it when i'm
listening to it and the brain gradually
does you just have to keep going
and and i think the many stories because
there's so much repetition
and because you have with link you can
look up the words in fact you also have
the translation if you're confused you
have the translations per sentence you
can hear it in the natural voice per
sentence and you just have to keep doing
the same thing and and listen more than
once and so go one two three four five
back to one and so here i'm suggesting
we're gonna go back now into cha into
lesson 11 of the many stories but i'm
hoping you'll continue to review the
earlier ones
do the next five mini stories and
continue to explore
uh you know wherever else you're
interested so maybe maybe we should do
that maybe we should move into the
into the mini stories let's do it
okay so uh and i think for the time
being i if i'm in a new language a
difficult language one that i'm sort of
a1a2 i always use sentence view
great that's really good advice too yeah
um straight from the guru
well it's just anything you can do to
make it easy is good in language
learning so you know like bilingual
dictionaries i only use bilingual
dictionaries i don't want to be
struggling looking at a meaning written
in the target language where i don't
know half the words
so we get the uh we get the translation
in our language
and we can listen to it yes for sure
so why don't you try reading the songs
property
okay so it's la partemo
la patama
so you have to there it's going to take
you a long time to get rid of your
spanish uh
training okay
it's just
that's just how it is
this is i can tell you
habits
carry over from one language to another
and they are very difficult to get rid
of yeah and uh for example when i
learned the russian you know cyrillic
alphabet where p is pronounced r i mean
six months in i would see the p and i
would go p yeah
so it's just you can't expect habits to
disappear so but let's try again read
the sentence again okay
perfect you even said petit whereas your
spanish tendency would be to say petty
but of course it's petty and benoit you
got that right okay yeah that's a name
and there was someone who also asked you
know how do we decide between
ignoring a word and
not ignoring it and link and so i just
ignored that word because it was a name
and again
you're going to want to do this the way
that it works best for you there's no
hard and fast rule so
um i've been
ignoring proper nouns only but i'm like
for example i would save
le partema
and probably just apart the month
without
the l apostrophe as well because that's
my preference because i want to know how
to how to say him both ways but i don't
know if you have a different way that
you would well i think it's important to
remember that the statistics are for the
use of the learner they are yours they
are not for bragging
to other people because every form of
the word is different
some people may choose to save names or
they say my mistakes say the name it
really doesn't matter it's entirely for
your own use i'll tell you i tend not to
save names
and the statistics are for our own use
and
as you spend more time on link you can
go to your
you know
profile
and you can see the historical record of
what you have done
in the language which is kind of fun
and
no one else is coming to my profile i'm
the only one going to my profile and i
can see how many words i've learned how
much i listen and i can see it
historically back over six months back
over two years so yeah the statistics
are for yourself but they are motivating
because it indicates that when you're in
the sort of doldrums or you have the
feeling you're not getting anywhere you
can look at the statistics and see that
in fact you are you've learned more
words yeah exactly so make it make it
yours i think that's what's great about
link is that it's so customizable and so
many different ways and the stats are
one of them so make it work for you
all right next page yeah
okay
very good very good
so uh
i mean i'm more familiar with the word
de minaje which is to move away
is to move in
uh
so um
i i don't think that's a very high
frequency
verb but it doesn't really matter
uh it starts to
start to make you familiar with the
sense of dementia
you know the word menage
have you heard of menage
no i'm thinking eat but that's monsieur
that's
so they talk
have you heard of that term i have yeah
so menage is like a home it's like uh
something along those so the word
it comes up so you start to become
familiar with with that uh word but the
word ominoge in itself is not super
super high frequency but it doesn't
matter you can't just deliberately try
to learn all the high frequency words
sure yeah well and that's why um i see
this one only comes with one coin the
the more common words have uh come with
more coins and i like that as a good way
like a good rule of thumb for me when
i'm like is this a
am i gonna use this sometimes i just
look at how many coins are associated
with it
i do the same but if you're listening to
the story many many times as you're
supposed to
uh this will become part of your you'll
understand you have to understand the
text so you may not maybe recognize that
word immediately but you'll be
understanding the text sure so and are
you going to save up them all this time
you're going to take it as a norm
i am yeah i'm going to i know this
you know
okay and read the sentence again
is very very important okay
and you'll notice that contrary to some
situations that t doesn't carry over
right i don't know what the rule is but
uh sometimes it doesn't sometimes it
doesn't
so i don't know maybe mostly the t
doesn't but i can't remember for sure i
haven't been um listening to the mini
stories as much this last week as i
should have been but right listening to
the music i think has been really
helpful just because you get used to
those like very tiny things like that
you know and i know sometimes someone
commented music isn't the best way to
learn because sometimes it's like not
proper language but at the same time
i like to learn the way people still
play with the language you know what i
mean like
yeah we don't have to always speak
proper formal english in everyday use
because we're native speakers so you get
to learn like proper stuff in many
stories and other texts and then you can
also learn
uh
informal ways to use the language too
which i think is interesting maybe other
people don't
i mean i i my view of the many stories
is that they're the core that's like
your i don't know if you go and work out
at the gym or anything but you have your
core exercises you want to build up your
basically your core right that that
makes that's very good for you in terms
of any physical activity so i see the
mini stories as the core and then you go
out and explore and do other stuff
and the exploring is fun and brings in
other things that you notice anyway
let us see here
all right
here we
make sure if you're going to pronounce
the e at the end
voila or it disappears oh it's almost
like a non sound right
right
photo
so
uh one of the interesting things about
day and again i'm not saying this so
you'll remember it but it's just a
suggestion it has the meaning of some
right
so he looks at pictures
of course in english pictures means some
pictures right yeah
it's not the pictures right
it's some so they often
will see it often where it has
definitely has the meaning of some
so
photo
[Music]
all right
and photographs
but what happens if you say de photo
if i say
if you make the phrase
oh
like what's the translation what do they
give you oh pictures okay
yeah i would have saved i would have put
the meaning as some
pictures anyway it doesn't matter well
and i noticed that in french
you'll
like
the day will come before nouns and in
ways that you don't always
you wouldn't insert that in english
like
um like you said like if i say like he
looks at photos
you don't need to say like he looks at
some photos you could but like it's just
not necessary and i don't know what the
rule is but it seems to me like there is
a rule in french where in some cases you
have to use the di before the noun
because
i see it used in many many cases is that
is that right the door and the day is
involved with quantity in a way that i
can't
tell you any rule but you know it's boku
do
yeah many
many
boku der photo
in english so the dou is in there for
quantity it's just something to think
about it's going to come up again and
eventually without knowing the rule
you'll start to get used to it
cool
photo that brought them on so are you
going to save that again or you're just
going to know it
i'm going to know it i think so
okay
you want to do one more sure all right
a lot of you know not that that's a
difficult word but a lot of stuff does
repeat in the many stories and we're not
even going into the second version where
here is ila he does this than the other
the next version is i is that the other
yeah and then we have the question so
all the stuff repeats about five times
in the mini stories that's why they're
so good
to listen to over and over again
read more than once and that's how the
fog lifts because the brain starts to
form
some sense of how the language works
anyway let's read this absolutely
all right um
lund
one of the apartments
because any time a word ends here's a
rule anything that ends in ent
is masculine
really okay i had
there may be exceptions i don't know of
any example but there could be some and
because and what you got to think of is
how do you say apartment in spanish
department
well or apartment is it departamento
maybe it is sure living in chile that's
how yes okay
i think you're right
uh often i find that in french the
gender is not so obvious
where for example the word vocabulary is
that masculine or feminine
vocabulary right vocabulary i'm gonna
guess masculine right how do you say
vocabulary in spanish vocabulary okay so
whenever i'm in doubt i think of the
spanish word okay because in spanish you
get the o so it's very likely to be
masculine whereas in french now
vocabulary ends in e
lots of words that end in e are feminine
so it's not obvious
but if you think of the spanish
equivalent you'll know whether it's
masculine or feminine so but that
doesn't help people that doesn't help
people who don't speak spanish now
learn this
so read the thing again
no no i don't want to hear the end at
all it's just total nasal you don't want
to hear the n okay
and um
what else was i going to say yeah beau
marche is one of these terms it means
cheap right
good market okay it's just that's what
it means it doesn't mean good market it
means inexpensive
yeah i saved that um
right phrase
so i mean this the fact that it's
difficult sometimes with the nasal as as
i say always the uh
and the nasals are hard
and in as in so much in language
learning you know whatever seems
difficult in week three
is easy by week
you know 15.
so people get frustrated because they
can't nail things early on they can't
remember things they don't understand
things
and i can tell you having done it in
languages as strange as persian and
arabic you just have to continue
and so
because i'm saying you just have to
continue i suggest we stop now
perfect
okay
and and uh yeah so
the point in these is not to explain the
whole language and give people a bunch
of rules to memorize the in our guided
course the first four weeks are just to
sort of
de-stress the situation make you notice
a few things
don't expect you to learn any rules
don't expect to learn any vocabulary you
continue to work your way through the
mini stories or through your songs or
whatever else you're exploring and
you'll just see that naturally things
become easier and then in the second
four weeks we're going to start speaking
some french
and as i say again
if there are people out there who want
to do this for say for their english
using portuguese as an example
uh please let me know and i'm not yet
started on my urdu but down the road i
will be and i'd be looking for someone
to help me on urdu when we get urdu at
link
but if there are people arabic or
persian speakers who want to help me
walk through some of my very difficult
texts
from al jazeera where i've had them
transcribed
we could do some guided courses in that
way as well so it's something that i
want to explore as a as a companion to
to link
great well we'll be watching the youtube
comments for anyone interested okay
thank you shelby thank you steve bye bye
[Music]
you